vous ne trouve qu'une bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors depuis le
début de l'année on le dit le kazakhstan
est le théâtre d'émeutes une situation
qui attire l'attention de la communauté
internationale à cause des violences
mais aussi parce que le pays regorge de
richesses
alors tout à fait le cas sachs vient de
le voir regorge de richesses à la fois
donc pétrole l'uranium est par ailleurs
adopté et en lisant avec ça beaucoup de
compagnies étrangères occidentales ou
chinoises sont présents dans le pays
donc elles ont évidemment vous intérêt
direct dans ce pays et l'évolution de ce
pays est importante elle est pour les
pays qui sont discrets les pays
occidentaux et la chine donc ça c'est un
aspect le deuxième aspect c'est que là
le kazakhstan n'occupe aucune place
stratégique sur les voies reliant la
chine l'asie orientale plus largement et
l'europe mais aussi
l'asie orientale et l'europe et l'homme
l'asie occidentale c'est à dire en fait
tout ce qu'on appelle les nouvelles
routes de la soie donc tout ça fait du
du kazakhstan un lieu de
stratégique ou bien sur
l'évolution du pays
ne peut pas laisser indifférent ce qui
explique évidemment si pourquoi les
relations et les réactions
internationales sont parfois un peu
mesuré et hésitante alors le kazakhstan
premier pays producteur de pétrole de
l'asie centrale quel effet les récents
événements peuvent-ils avoir sur
l'économie de l'ordre dans la région
je dirais même plus largement que sur la
région ça peut avoir des effets sur
carrément sur les prix à l'échelle
mondiale
donc évidemment la situation
pour quelques jours les choses ne vont
pas forcément être modifiée mais bien
sûr tout l'enjeu est de voir que la
situation 5 se calme le plus rapidement
possible ce qui nécessite évidemment des
mesures politiques puisque le
mécontentement de la population est très
certainement réel telles conséquences
également pour les nombreuses
entreprises étrangères qui sont
implantées au kazakhstan l'ajustement on
le problème est là alors c'est vrai que
le kazakhstan au cours des années
précédentes avait vu plusieurs vagues de
grève plusieurs tentatives de créer des
syndicats alors on a parlé évidemment
d'ingérence étrangère ce qui est pas
forcément exclu mais il ne reste pas
moins que on a déjà une certaine
ébullition dans le monde du travail
kazakhstanais depuis plusieurs années en
fait depuis même plusieurs décennies en
fait depuis l'indépendance et les
événements actuels montrent que le
mécontentement est très certainement
monter d'un cran suite aux mesures
libérales parce qu'il faut bien le tir
le gouvernement tokayev amené un certain
nombre de mesures libérales
l'augmentation du prix du gaz
directement liés à cette idée de
dissocier d'une économie de marché mais
on a vu aussi la réforme des retraites
récemment au kazakhstan qui a aussi
beaucoup heurté une partie de la
population
la russie on en parlait vous vous disiez
qu'elle est très central aujourd'hui
qu'elle occupe en tout cas une place
centrale dans l'économie du kazakhstan
mais depuis des années 2000 la chine
commence à y jouer un rôle de plus en
plus important
pékin est elle proche des 20 c moscou
selon vous
la chine et la russie en ce moment pour
toutes sortes de raisons sont comme on
dit condamnés à s'entendre pour des
raisons beaucoup plus plus large du
vaste
ayant trait à la situation
internationale général donc en fait le
problème - entre la chine et la russie
au kazakhstan qu'entre la russie la
chine et les occidentaux qui sont aussi
très présents kazakhstan dont je voulais
parler des entreprises occidentales mais
depuis depuis le
lever plusieurs années le kazakhstan
même ce qu'il appelle une politique pury
vectorielle ou multivectorielle qui est
une politique qui se voulait d'équilibré
entre les pays occidentaux la russie la
chine et l'iran
ce qu'ils
pouvaient disons mécontenter parfois la
russie la chine ville les tensions
internationales qui déborde largement
l'asie centrale en l'occurrence alors on
sait que ces émeutes s'inscrivent dans
la prise de pouvoir du nouveau président
kacem sont mortes à kiev après la
démission surprise du dirigeant
historique
nazarbaïev alors quel est le bilan de
cette nouvelle présidence qui semblait
encore contrôlée de l'intérieur par
nazarbaïev est ce que la présidence
actuelle tente de s'éloigner de son
influence c'est un véritable alors c'est
une énigme pour le moment on n'a pas
tous les éléments en main mais
l'hypothèse qu'il y ait des
contradictions grandissante entre
l'ex-président qui jusqu'à qu'il ya
quelques jours était toujours président
du conseil de sécurité et le nouveau
président n'est pas du tout exclu on
sait évidemment que le kazakh c'en est
une économie très fort très largement
comment cette idée très oligarchique et
on a différents clans oligarchiques et
on parle souvent au kazakhstan deux
clans proches de l'ancien président et
que le nouveau président serait proche
d'autres clan d'oligarques et que tombe
du coup des contradictions serait apparu
le fait est que on s'étonne qu'à almaty
les
l'armurerie ait pu être ouverts 6 me
dire aux émeutiers
donc on parle de groupes armés tout cela
laisse de fait courir des rumeurs sur
des tentatives de coups d'état de deux
conflits à l'intérieur du régime on n'a
pas les éléments suffisants ou à
répondre à la question mais l'hypothèse
est effectivement intéressant une
dernière question très rapidement le
président kazakh a laissé entendre que
des étrangers je cite sont à l'origine
des troubles est ce une manière pour lui
de laisser entendre que la contestation
est noyautée par une puissance étrangère
oui bien sûr ça c'est alors ça fait
partie disons ddd des réponses
habituelles d'un dirigeant attaque et
d'essayer de présenter les tensions
comme venant de l'étranger il n'est pas
pour autant totalement exclu que des
ingérences et lieu eux
en particulier n'oublions pas que la
turquie a
formé en syrie des djihadistes d'origine
kazakh
que
les rapports que le directeur de la bm à
6 des services secrets britanniques et
l'ancien ambassadeur britannique en
turquie est très proche d'erdogan tout
cela fait courir des rumeurs sur une
ingérence deux réseaux jihadistes de
réseaux peinture kyste au kazakhstan est
ce vrai nous n'en avons pas encore les
les éléments la preuve donc il faut être
très prudent par ailleurs
le chef des talibans afghans a
envoyé son appui au président
kazakhstanaise qui laisserait entendre
évidemment que les cas de que les
talibans qui on le sait aux en
afghanistan sont en conflit avec tech
offrant quelque sorte leur appui régime
kazakh ce qui la méritent aussi intérêt
donc on voit évidemment que
l'association est extrêmement compliqué
les acteurs sur le terrain extrêmement
nombreux
et donc évidemment les rumeurs une
ingérence sont tout à fait fondé même si
pour le moment il est trop tôt pour
pouvoir donner une réponse disons
catégorique sur la question en attendant
que le pouvoir kazakh ce cas nous les
présente si tenté qu'il en a merci en
tout cas vous risquez d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste de l'europe de l'est
historien et maître de conférences à
l'inalco